It is great to welcome today Dr. Bandy X lead
to the program, who is a Yale University forensic
psychiatrist.
And this is maybe a field, Dr. Lee, that not
everybody is familiar with.
Can you talk a little bit about forensic psychiatry
and the work that you do?
Yes.
Forensic psychiatrist works at the interface
of psychiatry and the law.
And so in terms of my clinical work, I mainly
work in prisons or state hospitals where many
legal issues may become important.
And we do evaluations for courts such as capacity
to stand trial or criminal responsibility.
I do civil cases such as asylum cases.
And I also have been teaching at Yale Law
School for 15 years.
And so there's a lot of overlap between the
law and psychiatry.
So one of the the general skills and abilities
seems to be evaluating sort of the state,
the emotional state, the cognitive state of
individuals, often in the context of criminal
proceedings, but also in other contexts as
well.
Yes.
So you have grown quite a following on Twitter
and elsewhere because of some of the observations
you've made about the president, Donald Trump,
and and to to make it totally transparent
to the audience.
You're very concerned about the behavior and
the actions of the president.
When when did this first become something
you started paying attention to and started
to speak out about it?
What was it that you were seeing from the
president?
You know, I was very distant from any of the
political world and was mainly working as
a clinician and academic.
And although I have consulted with a number
of governments on public policy and prison
reform in particular, I had not considered
politics to be a domain for me to speak about.
But the day after Donald Trump's presidential
election, I was contacted by numerous members
from the public, from civil society members
and others who had known of my work.
And so I was inundated with phone calls and
messages.
And I had to think to myself, if I have been
working as a violence expert, which is my
area within forensic psychiatry and also in
public health, I had been working to prevent
violence at multiple levels.
Individual, collective, societal.
And would I turn away from this situation
when it poses perhaps the greatest level of
danger that we could ever face and potentially
be a trigger for the greatest amount of violence
in society?
What were the first behaviors of Donald Trump's
that that made you realize that there's that
possibility of danger and violence?
Well, there are many trigger signs that we
look for in terms of danger and violence proneness
and and because past violence is often an
indicator for potential future violence.
We look at things like verbal aggression,
history of boasting about sexual assaults
and inciting violence, as he has done at his
rallies and definitely during the presidency.
He has taunted allies and enemy nations with
nuclear power.
And all these are signs of danger.
Of course, there are also psychological characteristics
that he exhibited, including impulsivity,
recklessness, a need to constantly burnish
a sense of power, preoccupation with a grandiose
sense of self image.
All of these things are associated with violence
and therefore things to look out for.
So inevitably, and even in the responses that
you sometimes get on Twitter, people will
bring up the Goldwater rule, the Goldwater
rule.
You're not supposed to diagnose.
You're not supposed to assign conditions to
people who you have not examined in person.
And increasingly, I'm reading more and more
about how that was really a sort of political
convention more than any kind of some sort
of definitive clinical consideration, and
that it dates back to Barry Goldwater and
the idea that there was an effort made to
prevent so-called armchair diagnosis of what
of what we're concerns about, about Goldwater.
Before we go further, maybe you should address
that in terms of what what is OK for you to
observe and comment on having not examined
Donald Trump in person?
Well, first of all, the Goldwater rule is
unusual in that it was, as you say, a political
compromise that was not it did not derive
out of research or.
Clinical concerns or professional practice,
but rather out of a lawsuit against popular
newspaper at the time called Fact Magazine,
which had done a survey of psychiatrists,
and it was unusual for the American Psychiatric
Association to come up with an ethical, so-called
ethical guideline in response to political
situation.
But under the Trump presidency, it has certainly
been abused.
It has also been modified about a couple of
weeks after a couple months after Donald Trump's
inauguration.
They modified it to cover not just diagnosis,
but any comment on a public figure of any
kind that actually goes against the original
Goldwater rule because the original Goldwater
rule was an affirmative obligation and that
we should participate in activities that promote
public health.
And so when we're asked about a public figure,
we should educate the public to improve its
health and well-being, just not diagnose,
because the diagnosis you cannot do unless
you have all the medical records.
And nowadays we do diagnosis not by personal
interview alone, but by external observation
and getting collateral information from those
who have directly interacted with the person.
So.
So one might say that the rule has also been
invalid since 1980.
Definitively, it was considered an outdated
since its inception in 1973.
But since 1980, our diagnostic practices have
changed that we don't just rely on a personal
interview.
So that having been clarified.
I'd love to get your perspective on that.
Where or if sort of some different areas of
concern with the president overlap or where
they are separate.
So you've already talked about the sort of
personality traits past glorification of of
alleged sexual assaults, etc.
You've kind of outlined that we then have
his assertions about the cognitive test he
has taken and claims to have passed that we
believe, is the Montreal cognitive assessment,
which includes identifying a few animals counting
backwards from 100 by seven, drawing a clock,
remembering words, etc..
There's that piece.
And I'm curious if and how that interacts
with your observations so far.
And then there is also these the mispronunciation
of words yesterday, in fact, repeatedly referring
to fatalities as fatalities and having an
expression on his face that he seems to know
he's saying something wrong, but unable to
correct it.
The orange is of an investigation is another
example where there was an expression of recognition
that something was wrong, but unable to say,
oh, no, I mean, the origins of an investigation.
Are these three categories related?
Are they separate?
How do they relate?
If so?
So.
I had been listening to Donald Trump's interviews
about this recent so-called recent cognitive
tests that he's taken.
And it turns out it is the test that he took
over two and a half years ago under White
House Doctor Ronnie Jackson.
Yes.
And and you're correct in that it turns out
to be the Montreal cognitive assessment, which
really is not.
It's first of all, not a fitness exam, as
Dr. Jackson tried to assert it was.
And also, it is not even a good cognitive
screening because research studies have shown
that full blown Alzheimer patients and hospitalized
schizophrenia patients can equally ace the
test.
And so, therefore, the Alzheimer's Research
Consortium came out stating that the screen
should not replace a full neuropsychiatric
or neuropsychological examination when it's
indicated.
Well, for the president, it certainly is indicated
because he has shown not only numerous, multiple
very grave signs of cognitive impairment as
well as decline over time.
We have considerable information on him because
of multiple public appearances over time.
And it shows a pattern of decline that is
recognizable for clinicians, in other words.
Often people become concerned about Joe Biden,
for example.
But in comparison, Mr. Biden's impairments
are superficial and more recognizable as non
concerning ones, whereas Mr. Trump's impairments
are fit the pattern of very serious ongoing
cognitive decline that is related to his own
family history of dementia, which he would
be predisposed to because of this family history.
And now I'm not really making a diagnosis
here because I'd like to point out that this
can indicate multiple possibilities of cognitive
decline.
For one does not simply come about because
of dementia or other neurodegenerative diseases
that can occur because of stress, because
of worsening psychiatric conditions that he
may otherwise have, or it can be a whole host
of other things.
So that's why we don't diagnose without having
all the medical records and without doing
a fitting examination, even if it doesn't
include a personal interview.
We need to do an examination of the data that
are that are appropriate.
And so what it does indicate, however, is
that we are seeing signs of very serious pathological
processes that need a thorough examination,
not a 10 minute screen like Montreal cognitive
assessment.
And I believe that the president has been
bringing this up himself because he himself
is concerned about his own mental fitness.
He often brings up topics when he feels that
he needs to fight his own notions.
And, of course, others as well, that he may
not be fit for duty.
And he has very valid reasons for concern.
But he does this by trying to convince himself
that he that he is that.
And in addition to trying to convince others.
And so he is repeatedly bringing up this test
that he had done two and a half years ago,
I think relates to Dr. Ronnie Jackson, who
was a White House employed and as a military
officer, subordinate to the commander in chief.
And so he is he would not be in a position
to do a fitness test.
He does not have the independence, but he
still use this ten minute screen to declare
the president mentally fit in a press conference.
And so that in itself is is a considerable
breach of medical ethics.
I don't know whether or not he was aware of
his false declarations, but because of this
episode of his perhaps admin or administering
a test that really would not tell us very
much.
But doing so anyhow was perhaps an attempt
to reassure the president.
But above all, it ended up misleading the
public when when the public was raising many
questions about the.
President's fitness now Dr. Jackson has been
removed from his position about two years
ago.
And amid other allegations that would make
his medical ethics and standards of practice
questionable.
We're going to go to a break on the podcast.
TV and radio show.
But we'll have our complete conversation with
Dr. Leon on our YouTube channel.
The David Pakman Show.
David Pakman dadgum.